[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
en esta oportunidad nos acompaña carlos
fontanet jefe de imágenes de la estación
espacial internacional lleva más de 29
años trabajando en la nasa es mexicano
de origen y el encargado de cada aspecto
relacionado a las imágenes que llegan
desde la estación espacial básicamente a
él le debemos todas esas imágenes
increíbles que provienen desde el
espacio y este mes de noviembre
precisamente se cumplen 20 años desde
que la estación espacial internacional
recibió a sus primeros huéspedes y a
partir de ese momento estuvo habitada
continuamente la estación espacial
internacional es la nave espacial más
grande que ha construido la humanidad es
el laboratorio a más altura creado jamás
y de acuerdo a la nasa unos 108 países
han realizado más de 2700
investigaciones en esa estación señor
señor fontanos gracias por su tiempo por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
usted es considerado el guardián y una
suerte de steven spielberg de las fotos
de la nave
cuéntenos cuál ha sido su
responsabilidad en todos estos años no
imagino que habrá muchos tecnicismos
pero le pido que nos lo haga un poco
fácil
es muy fácil es muy fácil a bordo de la
estación espacial tenemos un gran número
de cámaras de televisión y de cámaras de
fotografía digital y constantemente el
día de hoy en esta época transmitimos 6
canales de vídeo de alta definición
desde la estación espacial 24 horas al
día esas cámaras se encuentran dentro de
la estación y también fuera de la
estación y pueden observar el exterior
de la estación espacial pueden observar
a nuestro planeta la tierra y las
cámaras interiores son para experimentos
no para ver a la tripulación y luego
tenemos las cámaras de fotografía
digital y sacamos aproximadamente unas
45 mil o más imágenes diarias de
experimentos de actividades de la vida
cotidiana de la tierra
y todo eso baja a través de un canal de
microondas así como se transmite la
televisión en todas las ciudades en todo
el mundo y así también transmitimos
nosotros las imágenes en vivo o en forma
de archivos digitales
las imágenes que capturan son muy
variadas desde la vida cotidiana de los
astronautas el espacio y la tierra
cuáles son las que más le han impactado
y le siguen impactando además se le
pregunta el porqué
bueno muy buena pregunta eso es
naturalmente desde un punto de vista de
gusto pues cosa de gusto personal pero
no haré como las imágenes de nuestro
bello planeta de las imágenes de los
océanos las imágenes de las selvas de
los glaciares se aprecian desde el
espacio en forma única y es lo que más
impresiona porque se ve la tierra se ve
en nuestro planeta tal y como es ahí no
se ven
fronteras no se ven cosas pues sé que
muchas veces nos preocupan mucho aquí en
la tierra sino que se ve tal cual
nuestro planeta es entonces en mi punto
de vista las imágenes más impresionantes
son las de nuestro planeta y también
cuando hay fenómenos naturales como
huracanes como
incendios como desplazamientos de los
glaciares todo eso se puede apreciar
desde el espacio es que desde hace 20
años han obtenido millones de
fotografías de diferentes áreas del
mundo lo que permite comparar cómo se
veían antes y cómo se ven ahora hablemos
del cambio climático que han podido
observar al respecto en estos años este
luso tenemos imágenes del programa de la
estación espacial internacional que como
habíamos platicado íbamos 20 años a
bordo por titulaciones pero
anteriormente había otros vehículos de
la nasa que también empezaban a tomar
fotografías de nuestro planeta entonces
nosotros le pasamos a las tripulaciones
listas o peticiones de ciertas áreas del
planeta que deben fotografiar entonces
por ejemplo nosotros podemos comparar
los glaciares
cómo se veían hace 20 años hace 15 días
5 y hoy verdad entonces se hace una
comparación y se puede ver claramente
qué
es el hielo de la cubierta de hielo en
los glaciares ha disminuido otro ejemplo
son las selvas nuestra zona amazónica
verdad en sudamérica este
ha cambiado mucho y eso se puede
observar a través de los años a través
de fotografías se han ido sacando año
tras año se puede ver claramente el
cambio de la selva y así también se
puede ver cómo hay erosión es como hay
deforestación es y muchas de las
actividades que hay hoy en día aquí en
nuestro planeta se pueden observar
precisamente desde la estación espacial
señor font anotara le quiero preguntar
si recuerda cuál fue la primera imagen
que ustedes registraron de la estación
espacial
debe haber sido una imagen de la
tripulación propia que llegaba de un
sector junto con sergei krikalyov y
conquisten y que son la tripulación que
llegó a la estación espacial
precisamente hace 20 años ellos tomaron
las primeras fotografías de ellos mismos
a bordo la expansión y una vez que se
iban estableciendo en aquella época sin
embargo la fotografía era en película en
celulosa entonces se tenía que
a tomar la fotografía sacar el rollo y
traerlo de regreso pues unas semanas o
meses más tarde es cuando realizará el
próximo vehículo desde la estación
espacial a la tierra hoy en día
naturalmente todo eso es digital y
prácticamente instantáneo
ahora todo lo que se graba se comparte o
hay cosas que por algún motivo no
en general la
de la nasa y el establecimiento de esta
agencia fue de una agencia civil para
transmitir el conocimiento adquirido en
el espacio a la humanidad entonces
de las imágenes de la estación espacial
son públicas
si ustedes van a una página de internet
que se llama imágenes de la nasa punto
gov
gv
ahí pueden encontrar una cantidad enorme
de imágenes que pueden usar libremente
siempre y cuando se pongan cortesía de
la nasa y hay muchas páginas de internet
de la nasa donde todas esas imágenes son
públicas no tienen derechos de autor y
se pueden usar para
o producciones para poner cuadros en la
casa para
lo que uno quiera la información el
conocimiento que se adquiere en la
estación espacial y las imágenes
generalmente son públicas
hay algunos imágenes que se toman con
otros fines de investigación o fines por
ejemplo cuando algo pudiera pasarle a
sesiones que se descomponga algo pues se
toman fotografías técnicas y esas pues
no se publican porque son más para usos
específicos por los cuales se han
adquirido apenas imágenes
el regreso a la luna está previsto para
el año 2024 supondrá el desarrollo de
nuevas tecnologías que están probando
algunas señor font anoche
naturalmente que si estamos probando las
tecnologías y donde las probamos a bordo
de la estación espacial internacional
por ejemplo
el equipo que tiene que llevar la
tripulación e instrumentos electrónicos
transmisión de datos todo eso es una
plataforma excelente en la estación
espacial internacional para volver a la
luna con la primera mujer que plantará
pie en la luna próximamente en el año
del 20 de 2024
y una tripulación de una mujer y un
hombre eso es lo que está planeando o
planeando para el año de 2004
cree que el hombre llegará pronto a
marte que avances cree que pueden
venirse en términos de presencia humana
en el espacio
es nuestro deseo es nuestra tarea de
explorar explorar el sistema planetario
e ir
a lugares más lejanos y el planeta que
más se presta para eso es marte sin
embargo como mencionaba yo brevemente
para ir a cualquier lugar hay que llevar
todo lo necesario para sobrevivir
entonces un viaje a marte es seis meses
de ida una estadía una estancia de otros
seis meses el regreso otros seis meses
entonces el viaje de ida y vuelta a
marte con el de un humano es de
aproximadamente de unos 15 a 18 meses
entonces imagínese si usted cuánto hay
que llevar en cuanto a oxígeno vive de
ese perro para todo lo que es necesario
para sobrevivir entonces eso no puede ir
en un solo vehículo nos va a ser es un
plan que ya se está desarrollando es
donde primero sale una nave espacial con
lo que sería
el lugar donde van a habitar luego
llevan los víveres luego llegan de
oxígeno y hasta el último llegaría a la
tripulación y eso va a suceder
probablemente en la década del 2030 si a
mediados de cada 2035 dentro unos 15
años aproximadamente pensamos que
podríamos llegar ahí
se nos acabó el tiempo señor fontanet
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 ustedes también gracias por estar
aquí en la entrevista en nuestro canal
continúe con nosotros
[Música]